sometimes too much of a good thing is a
bad thing such as the case for Gemini
man director angley's action thriller
featuring not one but two Will Smith's
one an agent assassin named Henry Brogan
played by Smith in a live-action
performance and another nicknamed jr. a
young clone of Henry sent to kill him
which Smith portrayed through motion
capture with Academy award-winning
director Lee at the helm action movie
icon Jerry Bruckheimer set his producer
Smith in the leading role and David
Benioff 1/2 of a game of Thrones show
running teen with a credit on the
screenplay Gemini man seemed to have
everything going for it on paper at
least but after literal decades of
development the movie sadly opened in
theaters to a decidedly muted response
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best in its opening weekend that
officially began on February October
11th Gemini man earned a measly twenty
point five million dollars domestically
internationally the film pulled in 39
million dollars bringing its worldwide
debut total to just fifty nine point
five million dollars several million
dollars under its reported production
budget of a hundred and thirty eight
million dollars to put things into
perspective fifty nine point five
million dollars is about what fast and
furious spin off hobbs and shaw yielded
during its opening weekend in north
america alone it's also a little more
than what John wick chapter 3 earned in
its first few days out also just
domestically so why did Gemini man bomb
at the box office let's take a look
Gemini man had the unfortunate fate of
opening the same weekend as a
family-friendly animated movie which
tends to draw in a good chunk of change
regardless of its quality and the
weekend after one of the most
talked-about films of Paul 2019 man it's
bombastic debut though the majority of
critics weren't impressed by it
MGM's The Addams Family managed to take
in 30 point three million dollars
domestically thanks to its star-studded
voice cast including Charlize Theron as
Morticia and Oscar Isaac as Gomez
released in time for Halloween The
Addams Family attracted audiences of all
ages sliding into second place at the
weekend box office absolutely crushing
Gemini man but not even coming close to
toppling the film in first place it
should come as no surprise that the
number one movie of the weekend was
Joker Todd Phillips gritty character
study of the infamous DC Comics villain
sorry and Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur Fleck
a failed comedian who experiences
something of a psychotic break and
transforms into the Joker the film
earned another 55 million dollars
domestically and 120 5.7 million dollars
internationally in its second weekend at
the box office bringing its total to
date box office take home to five
hundred and forty three point nine
million dollars it's also a bona fide
cultural sensation and basically all
anyone could talk about lately so it's
not shocking that Gemini man got bested
by the Clown Prince of Crime it's not
really Gemini man's fault that it was up
against some fierce competition but
unfortunately critical reception to the
film has also been less than optimal on
Rotten Tomatoes Gemini man holds a 25
percent approval rating from critics who
have taken issue with the movies
frustrating story its uninspired script
and visual effects that only sometimes
impress one critic Aidid Gemini man so
much that he described it as quote an
absolutely inexcusable Turkey a Gemini
man been a critical success it may have
had a better chance at the box office
though Gemini man tanked hard in its
opening weekend it still has a tiny
chance at success The Hollywood Reporter
has noted that the film is set to make a
splash in China where it will launch on
Friday October 18th however unless the
film pulls in hundreds of millions of
dollars in that international market
Gemini man could end up costing its
financial backers a ton of money sources
for deadlines have indicated that studio
Paramount Pictures is looking at a loss
of about sixty million dollars on Gemini
man hey is this ever having you before
your own government trying to tell you
that's new the bright side of this is
that Gemini man scamp box office
earnings probably won't get director
Angley down he shared reports that he
doesn't believe financial performance is
the definitive marker of a film's worth
Lee also shared that he stands by his
past films despite some of them
performing poorly at the box office
Lee explained you don't judge something
by its financial success or not I can
argue this all day I've been there
before
my last movie Billy Lynn I felt that I
was right and the whole world was wrong
but it doesn't matter
some may agree with Lee and others may
think he's talking crazy
either way Gemini man underperformed in
its first weekend out and it's looking
like that might spell big trouble moving
ahead check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite new movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you